bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce premier set
8 sport de la saison je suis ravi de
vous retrouver après cette pause
estivale tout de suite le sommaire weiss
beau les cougars de mantilles retourner
affronter souris cannes clermont ferrand
en demi finales des playoff
pas de miracle pour les outsideurs ini
montagne ils ont perdu les deux premiers
matches sur leur terrain nous
reviendrons sur cet événement dans ce
magazine
rugby les championnats reprennent dans
deux semaines pour les illinois à l'aube
de cette nouvelle saison nous pour un
pan complet sur les clubs de chevreuse
de plaisir de versailles du sky rugby
nouveaux entraîneurs nouveaux joueurs
ambitions tout sera passé au crible avec
nos invités nous évoquerons également
semble équipe de france et la sélection
du trappistes hédi ben arous avec les
bleus golf les préparatifs de la ryder
cup 2018 viennent de débuter le parcours
est actuellement en pleine
transformation pour accueillir
l'équivalent de la coupe du monde du
golf et détail dans cette édition est
peu en fin d'émission nous pourrons en
temps complet sur les résultats sportifs
du week-end dans le département et sur
la question de football avec trappe et
d'aviron avec thomas barrau clos
versailles
il n'y a pas eu de miracle pour les
cougars de montigny en demi-finale de
play-off de 2e division les inhumant
teint se sont inclinés contre clermont
ferrand score final 14 à 4 dans le
premier match et 9 à 3 dans le second
malgré cette défaite montigny espère
toujours se qualifier pour la finale
les images sont signés elodie moines
clermont ferrand est décidément la bête
noire des cougars de
montigny-le-bretonneux cette saison
après avoir perdu quatre formes en
quatre matchs contre les auvergnats
saison régulière désigne montant se sont
une nouvelle fois incliné à domicile en
demi-finale des play-off de 2e division
et saint quentinois n'ont rien pu faire
dans les deux premiers matchs de leur
série
score final 14 à 4 dans la première
manche et 9 à 3 dans le second acte on
avait pour stratégie en fait de décès de
rester proche au niveau du score parce
qu'il avait un bon lanceur américain
malheureusement on n'a pas pu le faire
on a commis quelques erreurs en défense
ils ont vite pris le large et après on
n'a pas pu remonter sur le score tous
les frappeurs frappe tous les frappes et
remettre la balle en jeu et ça c'est
vraiment un avantage contrairement à
nous qui avons pas réussi avec tous nos
frappeurs a frappé comme il faut pour
espérer se qualifier en finale de
playoffs les cougars n'auront pas le
droit à l'erreur lors de leur
déplacement en auvergne dimanche le 13
septembre une seule défaite sur les
trois matches les empêcheraient
d'accéder à la finale
ce qu'il faut actifs y est c'est
peut-être un peu plus de concentration
au niveau défensif et reprendre un peu
les automatismes de la saison en attaque
on a eu une coupure d'un mois
on a repris l'entraînement la semaine
dernière donc on n'est pas encore tout à
fait prêt on a montré de bonnes choses
maintenant il nous manque les
automatismes qu'on avait en saison et
alors qu'on les retrouve
très vite parce que les trois prochains
matchs la semaine prochaine le sans
faute et donc obligatoire pour continuer
de rêver à la montée en première
division la saison prochaine en finale
le vainqueur de la série montigny
clairement pourrait retrouver l'équipe
fédérale de toulouse qui a remporté ses
deux premiers matches contre la rochelle
on passe maintenant au rugby c'est
bientôt la reprise pour les clubs des
yvelines dans deux semaines les joueurs
fouleront à nouveau les terrains pour
s'affronter dans les mails ou
transpercer les lignes adverses pour
tenter de marquer un essai pour faire un
point complet sur cette nouvelle saison
nous recevons sur ce plateau guillaume
nero 9 coach de l'équipe 2 de versailles
brice trinquent trong de chevreuse
thomas païens du sky rugby et cyril
amendé le président de plaisir bonsoir
alors tiré l'amendé on va commencer tout
de suite par vous plaisir était en
fédérale 2 la saison passée vous
redescendez cette année en fédérale 3
est ce que enfin quelles sont vos
ambitions cette année c'est de remonter
tout de suite en fédérale 2 l'objectif
c'est de jouer le haut de tableau
normalement avec l'équipe
or plus les quelques renforts qu'on a
récupéré on dort et pérenne dans les
premières 1er ou 2e 3e place l'objectif
qui est assidu que l'on est comment
appréhendez-vous à cette saison
justement comment sont les joueurs non
le groupe ait eu l idée voilà deux
facteurs et cela voulait dire le droit
je vois un effectif de 60 personnes qui
étaient aux entraînements on a le match
amical d'hier la courneuve jouer dans
ton cas marquis de famille pour passer
en revue tout le monde et puis de
petites histoires on a gagné 22 douche
donc ça réconforte un peu le futur avec
bon rien n est acquis
donc il ya un nouvel entraîneur c'est ça
oui nous caviar vie ne s en va de la vie
d'alice est reparti donc on à l'arrivée
de jean miss qui était l'entraîneur de
protocole du troisième saison avec celle
ci qu'un peu naturel et il est avec fred
jardins historiques de l'entraînement
restée en trombe
est-ce que vous pensez que cette année
en fédérale 2 pour plaisir va les aider
justement dans cette fédérale 3 est ce
que ce sont les favoris du coût de leur
poule c'est plus facile que pour
cheuvreux ce qui monte d'honneur c'est
une certitude
maintenant oui d'expérience au magazine
le groupe reste sensiblement le même
renforcé donc oui ce sera je l'espère
pourra en tout cas une accession
peut-être à la fédérale 2 encore ils
sont pas dans notre poule donc je leur
souhaite ardemment tirer la demande et
il ya eu donc dix nouveaux joueurs c'est
ça dans l'équipe d'alf effectifs ça oui
on a autre quatre joueurs de dreux est
là qui nous ont rejoints dont un ancien
qui était venue il ya trois saisons
pierre cayron donc je dirais qu'il amène
son expérience derrière ceux là où on
était un peu juste également au niveau
de l'ouverture on a récupéré pierre
fayet fajol qu'était de à maisons
laffitte donc on a vu que ça mettait
déjà en place des danses bien de jeu y
amener le neuf est ce que c'est une
équipe plaisir qui est difficile qui est
embêtante à jouer pour versailles oui
après pause ne faisait pas mais vous
verrez avec versailles ça reste un derby
et puis depuis toujours quoi donc oui
donc c'est difficile à jouer mais
surtout chez eux
voilà ils ont une notion assez fade en
profite d'ailleurs de forteresse chez
eux quoi qu'ils aient c'est compliqué
aller jouer chez eux et à gagner donc
donc moi je pense en effet que la
fédérale 2 les standards fédéral doivent
alors faire beaucoup de bien enfin leur
a fait beaucoup de bien et leur
permettre de jouer notamment en fédérale
3 je pense tranquillement enfin
tranquillement force investissant pour
l'ec raismes mais je pense qu'ils vont
je pense qu'il voyait trois premiers de
leur poule
justement dans leur poule ils auront
donc evreux well ma maison et quand ça
devrait passer pour pur plaisir
sur ces trois clubs la dirai oui oui
marcq en baroeul je pense donc on va
passer maintenant à vous à versailles
donc l'année dernière vous game 0,9 dans
votre club vous aviez énormément de
jeunes vous misé beaucoup sur la
jeunesse est ce que cette saison ce sera
la même chose
oui et non pendant une génération un peu
qui équipe à qui appartient la pas la
retraite mais qui partit vers
l'entraînement plus tôt donc acquitter
club qu'elle te remplacer par des
recrues qu'on a
qu'ils viennent quasiment tout de la
réserve de suresnes donc on espère que
ces gars là vont apporter un peu
d'expérience leader ils viennent un peu
pour ça ils viennent tenter une nouvelle
aventure pour la dernière lors des trois
dernières saisons quoi se relancer un
petit peu donc voilà on espère que ces
gars là vont bien encadrer les jeunes
qui sont toujours là et puis la rupture
entre contrepartie pour un peu appuyé
sur ce projet donc son a créé une équipe
de l'ask depuis donc cette année où pour
l'instant les trois ans de 35 à 40
joueurs entraînements donc on espère
aussi que c'est de la sq un dc d'ici
deux trois ans on peut rappeler ce que
c'est c'est la catégorie une nouvelle
catégorie est écrit par la fédération
française de rugby
en tout cas qui va être qu'ils devraient
à jour obligatoire pour les clubs
fédéraux pour les moins de 21 ans a donc
entre les juniors ou moins de 18
et les seniors avant il n'y a pas de
catégories ont passé de -18 la senior et
aujourd'hui ils ont voulu je pense pour
contrecarrer un peu là
la division ce physique qu'on a
rencontrés à 18 ans de monter en seniors
doivent en trois ans encore pour évoluer
physiquement évolué techniquement évolué
sur le jeu promettent aux jeunes de
jouer apprend seniors sans trop se
blesser thomas payen cette jeunesse dans
un club c'est bon signe c'est mauvais
signe est-ce qu'il faut miser sur cette
jeunesse ça je pense que c'est
primordial surtout pour les clubs comme
nous dans l'est dans les yvelines où on
a toujours misé sur la formation va
parler plus tard des dix benarous qui
était un jeune de trappes
donc je pense que faut miser sur la
jeunesse aujourd'hui et si l'avenir
l'avenir de nos clubs et vit dans une
autre équipe on va intégrer la fédérale
3 vous y étiez vous est redescendu ou
remonter cette année donc en fédérale 3
donc c'est chevreuse
justement comment vous positionner dans
ce championnat vous allez essayer de
vous maintenir vous allez essayer plein
de monter pourquoi pas en fédérale 2
mais cette saison où et c'est tout
simplement son avenir la montée ça
semble très compliqué maintenant le plus
haut possible comme d'habitude mais
j'essaie de gagner le plus de matchs
possible le maintien ce sera le minimum
ce qu'on souhaite pour nos joueurs et
pour notre club c'est le maintien au
minimum et puis après si on peut aller
accrocher plus haut il fera grand
plaisir et les gens sont pas trop
stressé à cette idée de de remonter en
fédérale 3 sur la plupart ont vécu la
fédérale 3 il ya deux ans puisque
c'était pas si vieux que ça maintenant
il ya des juniors qui montent qui comme
disait comme des entraîneurs alors ça il
faut qu'ils s'habituent aussi à ce
niveau là c'est impact physique et voilà
on ça va changer quelque chose aussi en
mêlée puisque la mêlée le règlement va
légèrement changé donc les petites
adaptations mais on est confiant et puis
on va tout faire pour y rester impliqué
et vous vous êtes renforcer légèrement
on a perdu quelques joueurs on en a eu
quelques-uns donc c'est plutôt un taux
stable et à ce que des joueurs sur
lesquels vous misez peut-être cette
saison où un secteur de jeu en tout cas
un secteur de jeu on est plutôt une
équipe mobile on est pas on n'est pas
sûr été mais en tout cas on est plutôt
mobile jouant de ballons
ou plutôt le collectif que
l'individualité
c'est l'amendé je suis heureux c'est une
équipe embêtante aussi à jouer il faut
prendre des fondamentaux y voit ça de
moi c'était on les connaît et d'ériger
sur le réseau de large mais est repassée
maman en skaï rugby donc vous vous êtes
deux divisions en dessous c'est ça
exactement dans nos moeurs donc vous
l'objectif c'est quoi c'est vraiment
c'est de monter cette saison parce que
l'année dernière ça a été loupé
exactement
c'est la montée c'est une division qui
est assez sélective ya que le premier de
chaque poule qui monte donc à cette
année on a continué sur le même projet
que l'année dernière on s'est renforcé
je pense que le début de saison est
satisfaisant pour nous donc on est
vraiment sur la continuité de l'année
dernière avec du progrès donc malgré une
poule assez difficile je pense que peut
on peut viser la montée en honneur
et qu'est ce qui vous a manqué peut-être
la saison dernière sur les derniers
matches notamment je pense un peu comme
l'équipe de chevreuse on a un profil
assez c'est assez mobile du coup avec
moins de joueurs dansent donc peut-être
cette ce problème de densité physique
sur les matches importants des autres
classes d'autres de classement ça nous a
perturbés peut-être pas c'est peut-être
ce petit pas dit qui nous manque
aujourd'hui pour aller aller chercher la
division honneur et après la fédérale 3
dans quelques années d'instruction et a3
d'ailleurs vous affrontez pas en
fédérale 3 cette année un plaisir en
versailles à chevreuse sargueil
peut-être pour vous guillaume bref on va
s'arrêter sympa d'avoir une petite poule
sans déplacement quelque chose de ce
plaisir maisons laffitte et a besoin de
gros derby mais bon après c'est la fédé
qui a décidé ainsi donc le remplir oui
c'est ça donc on
on suit la fédé c'est vrai que bon on va
on espérait secrètement comme avoir des
clubs chinois
on en a pas plaisir nains mais même en
faisant le film donc un gros morceau
aussi ce serait surprise et l'année
merci à vous quatre en tout cas pour ce
tour d'horizon des clubs ynwa ne bougez
pas on se retrouve dans un instant pour
parler et di bella de hédi ben arous le
trappistes et de la coupe du monde de
rugby et tout de suite on passe au golf
après 25 ans d'existence le golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
temps plein lifting des travaux ont été
lancés cet été pour moderniser le
parcours et le rendre plus confortable
en vue de la ryder cup 2018 l'équivalent
de la coupe du monde du golf
les images sont signées pol de glaire
pour les images la ryder cup 2018 se
prépare dès maintenant au golf national
de saint quentin en yvelines
d'importants travaux de rénovation ont
été entrepris sur le parcours de
l'albatros depuis le 7 juillet dernier
pour accueillir la coupe du monde du
golf que d'une centaine d'ouvriers
jardiniers ont investi les greens pour
améliorer les 18 trous et l'accueil du
public
là on aura travaillé à une petite
amélioration sur des greens ou sur des
départs pour que vraiment les sportifs
puissent exprimer au mieux mais on a
aussi beaucoup travaillé pour la qualité
de l'accueil du public en faisant des
routes et des plateformes qui vont
permettre au public de circuler de voir
le golf le beau fond on a une chance et
qu'on peut aller au plus près des
athlètes et au plus près des sportifs
pour les voir donc
et on sait qu'on voudra énormément de
public ici les 200000 spectateurs
attendus à guyancourt pour la ryder cup
pourront également observé un parcours
plus visuel avec une dizaine de nouveaux
bon coeur les points d'eau vont
également être créés sur le site
il ya eu des changements et un
changement déjà durant ce parce que
c'était un trou qui manquait un peu de
caractère et on avait besoin d'un
endroit pour stocker de l'eau donc déjà
deux bonnes raisons pour le faire
et puis les deux autres changements qui
vont être remarquée sur le green du 1 1
du 16 mai qui en étaient rendus plus
juste pour le joueur mais aussi plus
facile à gérer lors d'un gros événement
voilà donc sinon il n'y a pas de
changement notoire
j'ai déjà assez difficile les travaux de
rénovation devrait s'achever en avril
2016 les golfeurs pourront jouer à
nouveau sur l'albatros à partir de
décembre
mais ce sera sur un parcours réduit avec
seulement neuf trous le golf national de
saint quentin en libye où pourraient
également organiser les jeux olympiques
de 2024 si la france est choisie
coup de projecteur à présent sur
l'équipe de france du rugby et sur eddie
vedder rousselot trappistes
nous sommes de retour en plateau avec
nos quatre rugbyman après des club
yvelinois nous allons parler donc de la
coupe du monde de rugby en angleterre la
compétition débutera le 19 septembre
prochain pour l'équipe de france de
rugby
le quinze tricolore affrontera l'italie
à londres dans l'équipe on note la
présence du trappistes elie benarous qui
a évolué au sein du sky rugby c'est bien
ça thomas payet va signer je crois l'âge
de 7 ans ou l asptt de trappes qu'une
association qui fait partie de saint
quentin en yvelines
et est ce que c'est un modèle du coup
pour pour les jeunes du club moi je
pense que c'est un modèle pour pour tout
le monde déjà parce que pour les jeunes
du club pour les jeunes de tous les
clubs en général c'est un jeune cassard
des qualités physiques on peut le voir
aussi aujourd'hui c'est sa capacité à
travailler à être eux aussi en
permanence qui fait que je pense qu'il a
ce niveau aujourd'hui
est-ce que sa sélection méritée sur roux
à brest en train n'a pas pléthore de 1re
ligue en france mais pour le coup ceux
qui sont arrivés récemment que la slim
and i et hédi ben arous sont vraiment de
qualité donc plutôt content sa sélection
il méritait largement c'est bien y
amener à 9 qu'est ce qu'il peut apporter
à cette équipe de france
qu'est ce qu'il apportait 20 par rapport
à un pc classique on va dire qu'il est
quand même plutôt léger donc il va
apporter justement son dynamisme et sa
mobilité et voilà il paye finalement les
calmes aussi assez tonique en mêlée et
qu'il ya une bonne tenue donc c'est
plutôt un bon élément pour l'équipe de
france et est
voilà donc il va espérons pour lui en
tout cas qu'il soit en aidant les dans
le quinze titulaire par le recteur ce
type de philippe saint-andré pour qu'ils
puissent bien belle coupe du monde et
pourquoi pas vous le voyez titré larbaud
doigté est ce que je vois titulaire je
suis pas spécialiste de la vallée et une
fille et première ligne esbly à l'heure
du conte profil intéressant mobile
après avoir et ce qui peut apporter
suffisamment techniquement dans le jeu
c'est ça reste à voir
parce qu'il ya très peu de sélections et
pas dans de grosses compétitions qu à
voir la coupe du monde des adversaires
aussi sila sahin gossip est à dire un
papa quoi quand il ya un an le premier
test ensuite l'argentine ou la nouvelle
zélande en quarts si jamais on passe là
ça sera des vrai test pour lui si jouer
donc c'est un genre que vous aimeriez
avoir dans notre équipe
oui bah c'est le saccage seront les
bienvenus j'espère qu'ils nous entend
revenant plus globalement l'équipe de
france est ce que vous pensez que
l'équipe de france peut avoir ses
chances si l amender b oui c'est du
monde et la coupe des voiliers ou
entraîneur c'est moins bien
c'est vraiment cette irrégularité qui
surprend donc je pense qu'ils vont en
quarts de finale ce serait dramatique
voilà après ils sont capables de tout on
avait vu du monde de plus c'est donc une
base
bon après c'est je pense qu'il faut
viser soit le dos au mur comme on l'a vu
contre les emblèmes sur le deuxième test
ou restreintes renvoie le match en ce
moment contre contre l'ecosse
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qui manque à
cette équipe de france pour peut-être
passer à un palier jouer après contact
principalement je penserai un simple
reflet s'impose que je vois le plus
plusieurs matches et l'équipe de france
c'est que là elle est pas capable de
jouer après contact de jouer dans le dos
des défenseurs et c'est compliqué parce
qu'un fou comme de sud-africains en
faisant 20 kg de moins chaque fois
c'était en étant un peu moins
technique et c'est un peu compliqué de
jouer comme ça l'épreuve de force tout
le temps et de rien créé n'ai jamais
créé des déséquilibres
je trouve ça un peu délicat maintenant
on espère que le frêche l'a encore vu en
quoi je reste sceptique lassus vous faut
pas nier que là dessus je pense je pense
qu'il a eu des partis dans les autres
nations je pense quand on voit les
centres écossais ou les centres anglais
qui sont capables de faire aujourd'hui
dans l'évitement d'en passer les gagner
son duel et que l'on n'est pas capable
dans lé kapab uniquement il avait tapé
dans le mur entre eux qui m'ont
communiqué pour moi c'est vraiment plus
dur c'est vrai envoyez vos idées non
mais voilà comment de créativité créa
grands tourments de créativité enfin
clairement fin on a un jeu comme tu
disais très stéréotypé un peu la suite
des années les années 95 2000 fin et y
en a pas les joueurs pourquoi donc même
si je suis sélectionné sudaf puis
sélectionnez cocotte et le rouet mais
bon c'est thomas payet ils ont fait
beaucoup de physique pendant la
préparation est ce qu'on pensait que ça
peut porter ses fruits
pas forcément c'est déterminant toute
façon à un moment donné faut passer par
là maintenant la part de physique par
rapport à la part de jeu est-ce qu'elle
n'est pas trop importante on verra
pendant la coupe du monde
moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui
moi je suis supporter ans ils m'ont en
équipe de france donc j'espère qu'elle
va aller au bout
ces risques on essaye d'être objectif de
regarder un peu ce qu'ils produisent
j'ai regardé comme vous le match à la
télé samedi soir bah c'est décevant
quand même parce que par rapport aux
capacités des joueurs individuellement
de voir ce collectif qui se cherche qui
a du mal à se trouver
c'est vraiment dommage parce qu'on voit
leurs capacités en club est derrière en
équipe de france
terrain manque d'automatismes peut-être
donc moins deux mois ne pourrait pas
physique pour plus de jeu pour que les
joueurs se connaissent mieux
moi je pense que ça nous c'est quand on
devine le physique se fait toujours avec
ballon on essaie de voilà qui est
toujours cette cohérence maintenant
chacun sont donc pour vous l'équipe de
france vallée au minimum en quarts de
finale ah oui je souhaite même bien plus
bien plus loin bien que lyon on va
sombrer dumontier je relève avec machin
folie folie quand il faut donc supporter
numéro 1 mais après c'est vrai que c'est
ça votre objectif sur les quatre
dernières années le bilan saint-andré il
est gentil nous sommes 20 secondes cela
est écrit merci à tous les quatre pour
cette analyse de l'équipe de france bon
courage pour la reprise du championnat
donc ça sera le week-end du 20 septembre
on continue à vous si on continuera à
vous suivre sur tv fil 78 ans passent
maintenant reste de l'actualité sportive
du week-end on commence cette page
résultat à part du football l'équipe de
football de trappes s'est imposé lors de
la première journée de promotion honneur
contre villemomble à domicile les
trappistes ont emporté 3 buts 1 sur la
pelouse du stade gilbert gensac
après avoir mené deux buts à zéro grâce
à ce tir à l'entrée de la surface de
réparation les trappistes on encaisse un
but sur penalty rapp a ensuite marqué
dans les arrêts de jeu pour valider sa
première victoire de la saison
à noter également que villemomble a joué
à dix pendant une grande partie du match
on écoute les réactions du buteur de
trappe sans bail du président moustapha
al ahmad
c'est super bien entraîné et là ça s'est
retrouvé sur le terrain on n'était pas
fatigué on avait le monopole du ballon
je pense qu'on s'est bien débrouillé on
commence très bien l'année avec une
victoire c'est toujours bien voilà on
prend réussi à y voir par la suite très
content normalement but surtout qu un
attaquant c'est bien pour le moral ça
nous met en confiance et très
sincèrement quatre points et dans un
championnat c'est important de marquer
d'entrée est donc une préparation qui
est tout à fait tout à fait honorable et
ses quatre points sont vraiment à
l'image de premier entraînement une de
l'esprit de ce groupe
après cette première journée trappe se
retrouve à la deuxième place du
classement de la poule c de promotion
d'honneur juste derrière saint leu en
joue également de mai 2e division de
district ce dimanche pour le premier
match de la saison et l'encours qui
jouait dans son traditionnel maillot
noir et bleu a créé la sensation en
s'imposant domicile sur le score de 3
buts 1 contre les favoris de cette poule
magny les hameaux
nous avons rencontré les deux coaches
avant la rencontre pour qu'ils nous
donnent leurs objectifs pour la saison à
venir l ambition c'est déjà de faire un
bon championnat déjà de bien démarrer
les ambitions on va on va les fixer au
fur et à mesure de la saison on va
essayer de tout donner après le football
voilà c'est il ya aussi une part de
chance donc on va essayer de la
provoquer et on va tout faire en tout
cas pour pour bien figurer dans le
championnat cette année
l'ambition c'est d'avoir une équipe
compétitive et d'avoir une bonne
discipline pour que les supporters
puissent apprécier notre football
l'objectif pour la montée c'est les
joueurs qui vont la chercher s'ils la
veulent ils l'apprendront sinon nous on
veut tout simplement en recréer un
groupe sain pour avoir une bonne image
dans les autres matches de 2e division
de district voisin bretonnet est allé
s'imposer sur le terrain de viroflay sur
le score de 5 buts à 2 guyancourt n'a
pas fait de détail face à rambouillet 3
0 montigny-le-bretonneux s'est imposé
contre bailly noisy 2-1 enfin mort pas
remporté une belle victoire sur le
terrain de jouy en josas 5 à 3 football
américain présent l'été a été dynamique
du côté des templiers d'elancourt
frédéric painchaud revient à la
direction sportive du club après 26 en
tant que joueur il aura pour objectif de
créer un projet sportif sur les quatre
prochaines années pour le club est en
cours thouars et aura notamment pour but
de nommer le staff de l'équipe élite est
de créer une catégorie pour les moins de
16 ans en aviron le versailles et thomas
baruch a apporté une sixième médaille à
la france ce dimanche lors des
championnats du monde organisés à
aiguebelette en savoie les quatre sans
barreur poids léger composé de franck
solforosi guillaume raineau thibault
collard et donc dû verser et thomas
barrau qu'à ramener la médaille de
bronze
la médaille de bronze habitué des 4e
place ces dernières années les français
ont réussi à devancer les néo zélandais
dans les derniers 100 mètres pour
l'emporter avec 95 centièmes d'avancé
sur les kiwis de bonne augure en vue des
jo qui se tiendront l'année prochaine
rio au brésil
on referme ce magazine par un
rendez-vous à montils bretonne un
hommage sera rendu au pilote jean-pierre
beltoise disparu en janvier dernier le
sportif avait participé à 86 grand prix
de f1 pour huit podiums et une victoire
une exposition sera organisée dans le
cadre de l'événement plein phare sur
l'auto programmé ce dimanche à la ferme
du manet de 11h à 18h deux de ses
voitures de course seront exposés pour
l'événement c'est la fin de 7,8 sport
merci d'avoir suivi je vous retrouve
lundi prochain pour un numéro spécial
jeux olympiques d'ici là passez une
excellente semaine sportive très belle
soirée sur tv fil 78